you know the solutions that you propose
are are pretty big government solutions
you're a guy who obviously worked in the
private sector and you ran a charity
that was specifically designed
for helping people in in the sector why
do you think that
stuff is is insufficient why isn't it
that it should just be about
private charity for example that's been
my proposal is that there needs to be a
lot more upswing in private charity that
we need to encourage people to leave
some of these dying towns you seem to
suggest that these people should
essentially be able to stay in these
dying towns and the government should
take care of them there
well i i think uh i think there are
several paths forward but we have to
choose one
and you know we have to figure out
together it's like what is the path
forward for
many many americans and the reason why
i'm confident that we need to
go bigger is that i was one of the most
celebrated social entrepreneurs of the
last number of years where i started
this multi-million dollar organization
venture for america
um you know movie made about us uh
honored by the white house
and i realized that our efforts as much
as i was proud of them were like pouring
water into a bathtub as a giant hole
ripped in the bottom
just the scale is all wrong where if you
look at the the numbers
we're looking at three to four times the
level of labor force
displacement as the first industrial
revolution or the industrial revolution
at the turn of the century
and so if you say hey charities are
going to handle that like charities
don't have the scale
to address needs this big and i know
this because i've
worked in that space and i've you know
hung out with the heads of foundations
and just the scale is wrong
for the uh scope of the changes so let's
talk about the crisis
itself so the the book in particular the
first half is is
rather dystopian about kind of its
description of the economy particularly
in certain parts and you do make
sort of a bifurcation between big cities
where you say the economy is growing
and some of the outlying rural areas
where you say that it's not growing
what about the argument that the economy
seems to be doing pretty well that every
time there's a technological change
historically there's been worker
displacement
that there will be people left behind
because that's just the nature of
creative destruction
but that new jobs will be created in
ways that we can't foresee right now
what makes you think that this time is
sort of the cataclysm
well uh we will 100 create many many new
jobs that we can't predict
and the issue is that they're going to
be for different people in different
places with different skills
than the the people that are going to
lose their jobs
like are going to be able to to take
advantage of
and so if you look at a couple of big
historical references
number one the industrial revolution
which people generally refer to and say
hey we've been through this before the
industrial revolution at the turn of the
century included mass riots that killed
dozens of americans and caused billions
of dollars worth of damage
we now have uh labor day as a national
holiday because of those riots
we implemented universal high school in
1911 in part as a response to these
problems
and bain and mckinsey project that this
time is going to be three to four times
faster and larger than that industrial
revolution in terms of displacement of
workers so even if you just rely upon
history you would expect
a lot of violence and tumult
and conflict number two i studied
economics in college and according to
economic theory if you were to automate
away four million manufacturing jobs
which we did
those workers would move get retrained
rescaled find new higher productivity
jobs and all would be well
but when i dug into the numbers it turns
out that almost half of those workers
left the workforce and never worked
again
and of that group about half filed for
disability
and then you saw a surge in uh substance
abuse and drug overdoses and suicides
none of which were in my economics
textbook it didn't say hey
like workers are going to go home follow
a disability and start dying at record
levels
so if you look at that fact pattern you
say okay that's what happened when four
million manufacturing
workers lost their jobs that's actually
a much better sign of what's going to
happen when the three and a half million
truckers and the two and a half million
call center workers and the over 10
million retail workers
suffer from the same sort of
displacement now the conservative
counter argument to
some of what you're talking about would
be right all these people went on
disability
but they were able to meaning that a lot
of people were able to find a social
safety net they've been reliant on that
social safety net that hasn't actually
rebuilt the forms of social capital
necessary to have functioning societies
you've seen
people who are supported by the
government largely who are still getting
addicted to drugs people who are
committing suicide at record rates or
staying unemployed for years at a time
and who are staying in towns where
presumably they really shouldn't be
staying i mean there are seven million
unfilled jobs apparently in the united
states right now and there are a lot of
people who are out of work
and people as you mentioned in the book
are basically staying where they are is
the incentive structure may be
misaligned because of government
intervention into the system you know
it's a very interesting question
and one of the things that i found
worrisome in the data
was that americans are migrating between
states
at multi-decade lows which is a terrible
sign for dynamism and i love
dynamism i think people should be moving
for uh for work it's very good
um economically and culturally it's
something very optimistic about moving
uh to some
to another state for a new job and so i
would love to help more americans do
just that and one of my
policy proposals that we pay moving
expenses for americans who want to move
because to your point there are a lot of
americans who are stuck in place
because they're underwater and a
mortgage there are costs associated with
a move that they can't manage
but a lot of them are also in place
because they have families and so
it's tough if you're going through a
hard time
and then you have like the only people
that you're close to in your life are
living in that same town and then you're
like hey guys i'm going to leave to
move to the big city you know you're
asking people in some ways to
to um sacrifice what little they can
rely upon in their lives
yeah i mean and i think that that's sort
of where i am in the sense that i wonder
if this is more about an american
mentality shift that has to happen as
opposed to government interventionism so
maybe we need to reinstall the sort of
pioneer ethos that supposedly animated
the united states in the first place
this idea okay you do have to pick up
and you do have to move and you do have
to make
difficult decisions to better your your
economic life
and do you ever worry that the
description of the upcoming economic
catastrophe
is actually disincentivizing people from
from going out and trying to forge forth
because i do think that how people think
has a major impact on on how they decide
to embrace the job market
well uh you know like you say uh you
know i mean facts are very stubborn
things
and so you know like i'm convinced that
we're let's say for example 30
of american malls are going to close in
the next um four years and
working in retail's most common job in
america i mean those are objective facts
like amazon's sucking up another 20
billion dollars in commerce every year
and so saying hey this is happening
i don't think that necessarily is going
to freeze people in place
like the hope is that we can galvanize
energy around folks trying to improve
their situations and adopting real
solutions
but i couldn't agree with you more that
there is uh a
mindset um that we would love to
have more americans uh inhabit and what
i'm going to suggest is that
there's something very optimistic and
confident about that pioneer ethos that
you described which is like hey i'm just
like go
and we're gonna make it happen i'm gonna
farm you know in some undiscovered
frontier and like we're gonna create a
better
life for ourselves and that is not
happening for a lot of americans so the
question is how do we get them
from where they are now to that point i
want to ask you about your perspective
on jobs because it seems like you have
an interesting view of jobs on the one
hand you say that people obviously need
them they need them for a sense of
meaning
on the other hand you seem to suggest
that those jobs aren't forthcoming
anytime soon so do you think that it's
the jobs that provide meaning or the
check
that provides meaning at one point in
your book for example you specifically
criticize this this
exact bifurcation uh you basically say
that there are two completely
oppositional ideas page 182
two completely oppositional ideas that
many people seem to hold simultaneously
first work is vital and the core of
human experience second no one will want
to work if they don't have to
well where do you stand on that do you
think that work is vital and people are
are going to work or do you think that
work is not vital and that this whole
can sort of be filled by the government
paying for it so
i assume that you you believe work is
vital i mean you talk a lot about it
in the book and you're you're you know
opposing that to the idea that people
won't work
if they don't have to but you're
acknowledging a lot of people aren't
going to work
right i mean your basic government
proposals involve a lot of paying people
whether they're working or not obviously
with the goal uh that we create more
work because i'm i'm very much in the
work is vital camp
and that's not just my uh thinking about
it that's just in the
data where if you look at what happens
to idle men in particular
we spend a lot of time on the computer
playing video games and doing other
things
we volunteer less than employed men even
though we have more time
our drinking and substance abuse tends
to go up
and over time there are some anti-social
patterns that develop
in idle men to a higher degree than
women
and so that's just data and so if you
look at that you say okay
this actually is pretty consistent with
my intuition that work is
incredibly important and vital it
provides structure purpose fulfillment
meaning social structures to
to people every day and so the question
is how do we create more
things like that now to me the best path
to create that
is to put economic resources into
people's hands in the form of a freedom
dividend
of a thousand dollars a month which
would then allow more people to do the
sort of work that
either they want to do or that their
community has a need for
um and the goal is to create jobs and
putting a thousand bucks a month into
people's hands would create
at least two million new jobs just
because the buying power would just go
right back into
local businesses and communities now all
that being said
i do think our definition our notion of
work should evolve
and one example i use is my wife is at
home we're talking about our families
my wife is at home with our two young
boys one of whom is autistic
and right now she works very hard i mean
she you know like she works harder than
than i do isn't you know i mean i'm
running for president and she's
working harder but the market values her
work at zero
uh society in some ways you know
minimizes the value of that work
and so to me we should broaden the
definitions of work to include being a
parent or caregiver but also
arts creativity entrepreneurship
journalism
things that we know people coaching
volunteering civic engagement people
things that we know people
want to do more of but that right now
society will systematically either
undervalue
or not provide not have any monetary
value
so i want to ask you about the the
location of meaning so i've heard as i
say
i think there's a point where the
populist left sort of meets the populist
right and the suggestion is that if we
structure the economy in certain ways
that this will
provide more jobs and that the jobs are
what are going to provide meaning but
you also suggest that
you know the freedom dividend while it
may create more jobs is sort of an
ancillary benefit there are a lot of
people who are not going to be able to
work who are going to be on the the
freedom dividend
who are going to be receiving ubi in
fact ubi studies don't show
increased employment in virtually any
study at best they show even employment
or declines in employment in the areas
in which they are tried
so where and then you sort of suggest
that people will be able to find meaning
and all the other things you're talking
about
volunteering and community and art but
we're not seeing that with disability so
people are dependent on disability
they're not engaging more in art making
or learning to play violin or
volunteering more
they're engaging more with video games
as you talk about or drug use
or or in some cases they become suicidal
we're seeing family breakdown
with all of that so what makes you think
the freedom dividend is going to have a
different effect
on human behavior than for example
current government welfare systems have
yes so three things the first is that uh
money does not somehow convey meaning uh
and you know the best it can do is maybe
provide
circumstances that help people find uh a
path towards
the some work that they find fulfilling
the second thing is i have a friend
whose sister is on disability and she's
afraid to volunteer in her community
because she's afraid she'd be
noticed as able-bodied and thus lose her
benefits
and so this freedom dividend would be
unconditional and free and clear and so
that person would be volunteering and
would not have any fear that
you know her benefit's going to be taken
away the third thing is that there's
something very very important
about conceiving yours of yourself as
either
able or disabled and so if you're
literally getting a check
for being disabled your two ideas of
yourself
are one i'm genuinely disabled which and
most people do have some kind of genuine
ailment you know physical
or mental or two i'm defrauding
our society and i'm actually totally
fine and i'm going to suggest that most
people
will fall into bucket number one that
it's like a rare person who's just like
i'm a hundred percent fine
there's a disability a check i'm getting
is just me being completely
fabricating some some condition and so
if you invert that mentality and you say
hey
you are not disabled you are fine you
are a citizen of the
richest most advanced country in the
history of the world and you you're
getting this cash and it's going to be
yours no matter what because it's yours
and you deserve it um
then that would be more constructive in
terms of pushing more people
into things that they'd feel good about
that society would feel good about then
if we say
hey there's something wrong with you and
we're going to give you this cash in
order to survive
so with all that said is your proposal
for essentially universal basic income
the freedom dividend
do you see that as substituting for the
vast agglomeration of welfare
state policies we currently have which
was sort of milton friedman's proposal
or do you see it as another dividend on
top of whatever is being paid we're
already paying tens of thousands of
dollars per household
in poverty in the united states in in
welfare yes
so my plan the freedom dividend would be
opt in
but if you opt in then you will forego
benefits from the existing programs
and so if you're currently receiving
more than a thousand dollars
in benefits then you'd look at this and
say hey like i'm
not going to do anything and my life is
going to be as it is if you decide to
opt in for the freedom dividend it might
be very appealing because it's
unconditional there's no administration
no case manager
it's a thousand dollars cash you can do
whatever you want uh then you forgo your
current
enrollment and so what what you'd see is
you'd see
we would shrink the role the enrollment
in the
um 126 or so different welfare programs
that we have
and then over time those enrollments
would go down which is very much the
goal
because the current programs no one
loves them
and they do have many uh unfortunate
incentives attached to them where if you
do better then you get less and so many
people are under reporting how they're
doing or
or constructing a world where they're
maximizing their benefits
so when we talk about the cost of this
thing and you talk about in the book
that we're on normal people you talk
about it'll cost maybe 1.3 trillion
dollars a year
that would be in addition to current
budgeting presumably
you know honestly that's that's
obviously a lot of spending off the top
but beyond that
it does raise the question as to would
this be limited in any way because every
government program
as ronald reagan said basically has a
bill of immortal life
and if it were to start at a thousand
dollars a month inflation adjusted
how quickly does this become somebody
saying you know what it really ought to
be three thousand dollars a month
because that's a popular pitch everybody
gets more free money where's the logical
limit
on that and how do we limit that from
just eating the rest of government
because entitlement programs
obviously are running us ragged now they
obviously represent two-thirds of the
federal budget
adding another massive entitlement
program on top that doesn't have a
limiting principle
how do we limit that so it doesn't
become the overarching goal of
government and actually put too much of
a press on
on the capitalist system yes so the
first thing is i would disagree with the
characterization of a dividend as an
entitlement program
and there's one state that's had a
dividend for 37 years and that state is
alaska
which is deep red was passed by a
republican governor
uh and he said look who'd you rather get
the money the government who's just
going to screw it up or you the alaskan
people and the alaskan said
us and he said i thought you'd say that
and then now everyone in alaska gets
between
one and two thousand dollars a year no
questions asked it's created thousands
of jobs
improved children's health and nutrition
it's decreased income inequality and
here's the kicker it's wildly popular
in a deep red state that hates taxes
because they see it's like this is one
of the few things the government gets
right like i actually get this dividend
it's great
i look forward to it it's real i can
spend it my kids get it like life is
better
as a result and so like it's different
from
an entitlement um in both uh its
structure
and uh the way it's utilized so that's
that's
uh big picture number one number two is
um
right now you're right about the fact
that our entitlement programs are
creeping ever higher in terms of both
proportion of the federal budget and the
enrollments where there are right now
more americans on disability than work
in construction
as one example and these trends are not
going to abate they're actually going to
accelerate
so the question is whether we're going
to try and restructure those programs
to something that we can all embrace and
get excited about that will actually
help keep american families and
communities strong
instead of waiting for more and more
people to get debilitated
by for example an automation wave that's
going to
displace the significant proportion of
the people that hold the most common
jobs in the economy which we're in the
midst of right now
and so the question is do you wait and
say okay like i guess we're going to
have more and more people
qualifying for these welfare programs
that have very negative incentives
attached to them
or are we going to own the reality and
say look we get it
we're going to have this dividend and
then we're going to reverse the
incentives of those programs over time
now to your question about like whether
there's a logical limit the reason why a
thousand dollars a month is so magical
is that it's enough to make a huge
difference in the lives of individuals
and families it's going to help
children's health and
graduation rates and mental health and
you know kids will have a real chance to
to learn uh will reduce domestic
violence or reduce
hospital visits um but it's not enough
to be a
labor replacement because twelve
thousand dollars is below the u.s
poverty line of twelve thousand seven
hundred dollars
uh and so people are still gonna have to
work um to prosper
and have a life that anyone's going to
be excited about
so my goal would be to put in this
thousand dollar dividend
and then keep it at that level but it's
going to be up to you know and this is a
big leap but we have to trust that
future legislative
legislatures will be responsible um with
the fact that
yeah good luck to that well but but
again you can look at something a lot
like alaska they've had over 37 years
and they've pegged it to a particular
resource
and so what what i'm suggesting is what
is the resource that we should peg this
to
and the resource we should peg this to
is technology where we have artificial
intelligence and
self-driving cars and trucks coming and
amazon this trillion dollar tech company
that's sucking up 20 billion
in commerce and causing 30 of malls and
stores to close they paid zero in
federal taxes last year
um and so what i'm going around saying
is like look that's not their fault it's
their job to pay as little tax as
possible
but that means we've done a bad job
designing a system if amazon's paying
less than federal taxes than you are or
you know he is or i mean i wonder if
that's true though because the fact is
that
you know we've focused a lot on
production but we very we focus very
little in this conversation on
consumption and the fact is
that you know when we talk about sort of
this halcyon past where everybody
was employed and people in manufacturing
industry were employed like you you
described at one point
the 1970s and i would read it because i
think it's sort of telling and
interesting you see some economic
problems existed growth was uneven and
inflation periodically high which
might be a mild understatement i mean
the 70s were not great economically but
income inequality was low
jobs provided benefits and mainstream
businesses were the drivers of the
economy
there were only three television
networks and in my house we watched them
on a tv with an antenna that we fiddled
with to make the picture
clear now i'm not nostalgic for a time
where i had three channels on a tv where
i had to fiddle with
the antenna there are obviously benefits
and drawbacks to the economy but the
fact is that people are living
significantly better on the average in
the united states than they were in the
1970s
if only from the ability to consume more
i mean the fact is that we
we everybody has a microwave everybody
has a cell phone everybody has a car
every i mean we're talking poverty line
folks have these things
uh so when we talk about what amazon is
not paying
the fact is that amazon not only is one
of the bigger employers in the country
but amazon is making
legitimately millions of lives better on
the consumption side so are we focusing
too much
on the production side as opposed to the
consumption side especially considering
that the number of people
who are affected by consumption is 100
and the number of people who are
affected by lacks of production jobs
are significantly lower than that well
you know it's one of the things that i
say in the book
which is that if you have um like this
focus on consumption like cheap stuff
and access to apps on your smartphone
um are great but they don't substitute
for having a functioning main street or
a job to go to
and so it's true that there are winners
and losers in this economy
unfortunately right now the losers are
outnumbered the winners significantly by
at least some measurements
and we talk about the 70s to now income
growth has
stagnated for many americans from the
70s to now in real terms
and the last three years we've seen this
declining life expectancy that's hand in
hand with a surge in suicides and drug
overdoses which is a sign that at least
some americans are experiencing
the lack of productive opportunity much
more sharply
than having access to cheap consumer
goods can can somehow make up for
no i think that's obviously true for for
a subset of the population it is also
true that for 100 of the population
the consumer we get cheap stuff yeah
yeah i mean it's not just
that it's pretty fantastic and great
stuff and if the idea of ubi
is that raising living standards on a
generalized level
results in in better outcomes in
a variety of areas then one of the ways
to do that is to
continue to provide that cheap stuff and
so there is a balance here i would
assume
i i like cheap stuff facts don't care
about your feelings and it's a fact that
the ben shapiro show
is the largest conservative podcast in
the nation be sure to hit the subscribe
button and stay up to date
on all of our content